the parents of a man who was killed in a  motorcycle crash flew into town to bring  their son's remains back home that crash  happened early yesterday morning  shutting down part of the 95 in the  northwest valley for several hours  aaron barris has now been identified as  the driver nevada state police believe  that barris was speeding onto the  on-ramp of u.s 95 when his 2020 suzuki  motorcycle wheel locked that caused him  to skid hit a median and he was thrown  off the bike now his mother was simply  too emotional to go on camera  he looked for that bike for a long time  and he just got it  about six or eight months ago  he rode every chance he got he loved to  ride he loved to write  we can also tell you that barris was an  army veteran and worked at his local  sheriff's department in florida recently  moving to las vegas so he could be  closer to his young son